kochi  it was a name that sounded so sweet so  seductive god meet the family everybody  this is patricia and this is my family  they had it all  worth style  power who wouldn't care for  [Music]  you bad nephew i have been the gucci all  my life  it is an empire  you can help the family which is not  exciting and everybody knows it at least  it's my name sweetie  our name  [Music]  which he needs sweetie blood poochie  is what i say peace this is not a  woman's game  remember that  madness who does he think he is  it's time to take out the trash  [Music]  gucci is a rare animal  it must be protected  protected  [Music]  who does what  oh  [Music]  don't  miss  [Music]  i don't consider myself a particularly  ethical person no but i am fair  i subscribe to  unconventional punishments  [Music]  you